the new Beats Studio buds plus look
awesome but are they worth it compared
to buying the airpods Pro 2 or the
nothing ear 2 well today we will find
out because we're gonna compare
everything from the design the battery
performance the sound quality active
noise cancellation microphone quality
which is important and more now I really
like the original Studio buds because
they had killer sound quality really
good active noise cancellation
especially compared to the original
airpods Pro when they came out so I
actually use them quite a bit but once
the airpods Pro 2 came out they crushed
them and now we have the new studio buds
plus and Vadim look at that
what do you think of this design it is
actually even better than I saw from the
images I can't believe how many
different components they have packed in
here you see the battery we see this
hinge mechanism uh with that top bar
let's check that out
all right that magnet actually seems
stronger than before and it's so cool
being able to see that magnet there that
magnet up top which is really large and
even an additional one right here where
the hinge is so this thing looks super
cool and comparing the cases I mean the
Beats one is the same as before it is
much larger than the airpods Pro 2 which
I love how small the airpods pro case is
it's taller longer it is thicker as well
so that is a downside now comparing them
to the nothing ear two well it's not as
tall which is good but it is longer and
thickness is about the same slightly
thicker on the beads personally I think
I would prefer the Beats because it is
not as tall so it's going to take up a
little bit less space be less noticeable
in your pocket let's take a look at the
earbud itself it is similar to before
but once again look at all the
components that are in there we see what
looks like the battery there or maybe
it's the case for the driver we have the
microphones we have some magnets and
some pins right here that is super cool
now the way this works as you guys see
it's stemless you actually have a button
up top that you press but it actually
looks different than the previous Studio
buds you can't click here you can
actually click at the top right there
and that actually feels nice it takes a
lot less Force than it did on the
previous one so let's go ahead and put
this in I want to test it out
so yeah very little pressure which is
great because before when you press down
the button would be large and it would
shift where it sits in your ear so that
is a nice upgrade but personally let me
grab and put the nothing ear in I
actually prefer this stem design where
you actually pinch to control it you get
a nice click it's really tactile and you
get less shifting in the earbud doing it
this way now popping in the airpods Pro
2 this has the same design that nothing
pretty much borrowed but the awesome
thing is this also has a touch sensitive
a surface so you can swipe down to
reduce volume or up to increase it and
at first I didn't think I was going to
use that very often but I started using
it more and more because of how
convenient it is now some people do
prefer the design of the Beats because
you don't have that stem you have less
sticking out of your ear and I could
definitely see that but in general it is
a little bit larger more bulbous because
of all the components they have to fit
into there and as far as weight I mean
both of these are so light and I think
they made the new beats actually
slightly lighter than before and the air
pods are actually a little bit heavier
and a bit larger than the nothing ear
now there is one major downside for me
with these beats and that's the fact
that they do not have wireless charging
that sucked with the previous ones and I
cannot believe that they didn't add it
to the new version that feels like
they're just doing it to help sell the
airpods Pro 2 because it has that these
can also charge with an Apple Watch
charger and makes it more flexible in
the nothing even though they're cheaper
have wireless charging built in so that
is a bummer for me but on the positive
the battery life is excellent the
earbuds themselves have six hours of
battery life with active noise
cancellation turned on compared to five
and a half with the airpods Pro 2 and
the nothing only gets four hours with
active noise cancellation and then with
the Beats if you turn the active noise
cancellation off you actually get nine
hours of battery life which is killer
and the nothing buds only get about 22
hours total charge compared to 36 on
these beats and then the airpods Pro 2
get 30 hours so the beats are definitely
a battery King now the other cool thing
is that you have fast pairing on an
iPhone but you also have that with
Android devices and it will actually
link to Android Cloud as well so appear
to your other Android devices just like
it does on an iPhone which you do not
get that functionality as well with the
nothing ear and the other cool thing is
that you get find my tracking for the
beats in your app which you won't get
with the nothing and you can also play a
sound to try to find them now as you
guys hear it is actually playing the
sound from the buds themselves not from
the case like you have with the airpods
Pro 2 with that speaker built in so it
is nicer if you lose the airpods you can
find them easier especially because it
basically has an air tag built into it
which will guide you to the exact spot
where they are at so that is definitely
a win for the airpods pro 2. and now
let's test out the active noise
cancellation I have this airplane sound
opened up right here and the beats are
supposed to be 1.6 times better active
noise cancellation than the previous
ones let's crank this up since airplanes
are loud and even without active noise
cancellation on these have really really
good sound isolation by themselves
because of the fully sealed design now
let's go into the app noise control on
all right wow
so that cut out a ton of that low end
but the high end is still very very
apparent and noticeable now uh let me go
ahead and pop these out let's put in the
airpod pros too
oh dang
that is way better the low end is
slightly quieter but the high
frequencies are a lot quieter about half
the volume compared to the beats and now
let's pop in the nothing here these
things are very close to the airpods Pro
2 the low end is identical better than
the Beats but the high end is somewhere
in between the beads and the air pods so
let me pause that right now and just say
that the Beats have the worst noise
cancellation it is definitely noticeable
now let's test how vadim's voice is but
even go ahead and say something
I hear you pretty well it's cutting out
some of your low end let's try out the
beads here hey hey how's it going you're
louder you sound more natural with the
beats and then lastly the airpods pro 2.
hey hey how do I sound with those ones
the most quiet the quietest out of the
bunch the high end is dropped down even
more so you still can't compete with the
airpods in terms of noise cancellation
now the Beats also have the transparency
mode which is supposed to be a lot
better because of the better mics let's
start out with the best of the best
Vadim go ahead and say something hey man
how do I sound good you sound pretty
much identical to how you normally sound
very good the nothing years how do I
sign with nothing you sound like you
have a cold
your high end is gone
the low end sounds normal but definitely
not good and I sound very weird talking
in these in transparency mode and now
let's try the Beats
you sound actually better than the
nothing your high end is still gone
but it is nothing compared to the
airpods pro 2. and now let's compare the
microphone quality these are the new
Beats Studio buds plus upgraded
microphones and this is their microphone
quality using the built-in mics in the
nothing ear 2. and this is the
microphone quality with Apple's airpods
Pro 2. and then one more time for the
Beats so you guys can hear them compared
to the airpods Pro 2 let me know in the
comments which one sounds better to you
because the previous beats had terrible
microphones now I did notice one very
weird thing about these beats as soon as
you start using the microphone if you're
on transparency mode and probably active
noise cancellation mode it actually
shuts that off and goes to the default
off mode and that is very weird because
you can't hear your environment whereas
the other ones in the airpods it will
stay in transparency mode and it sounds
a lot more natural and not something
that you can't read on the specs and now
let's get to the sound quality
comparison you guys can see my reactions
we're going to cut between uh the three
different earbuds and then I'll let you
guys know what I'm hearing
[Music]
unfamiliar bring me back
all right that was very interesting
first off the Beats don't shut off when
you take up out of your ears what the
heck is going on they don't have sensors
built in and I remember reading about
that but that is terrible for 2023 where
the other ones will now as far as sound
quality I also think the Beats sound the
worst they have a ton of bass the highs
are very crisp but they're harsh whereas
the nothing is very naturally tuned the
airpods have a little bit more highs I
would say the airpods sounded the best
the beat sounded worse and now let's
switch to our next track
[Music]
thank you
all righty well that song's a lot harder
there's a lot going on just like you
guys heard and the Beats once again
sounded the worst now the bass there
sounded fantastic but once again the
highs are very harsh even the vocals
sound harsh uh the instrument separation
isn't terrible but it is worse than the
air pods now that's not saying a lot
because the airpods they actually have
the synth that gets covered up by all
the other instruments it gets hidden in
that really tough track whereas the
nothing earbuds even though they don't
get as loud as the other two and I do
like my music loud they sound very
balanced all the instruments come
through the synth still comes through
the other layers of sound and the
nothing uh buds too there's nothing ear
two these sounded the best in that track
and you can listen at full volume for a
long time and not have your ears get
tired whereas with the beat that will
absolutely happen uh now Vadim what
about sound leakage between these three
I'd say that the beets have by far the
most especially like the sharp sounds
the highs yeah and that that is what was
just like hurting my ears and I like
higher sharper frequencies than most
people do so that is a bit disappointing
so I will have to say we tested these
two different tracks in the Beats even
though they don't sound bad in 2023 they
are a bit disappointing so if you care
about sound quality I would say go for
the airpods or the nothing these are
both very good and with that said for
170 bucks this case the translucent
version looks super cool and that might
be the biggest selling point about these
the no voice cancellation is isn't as
good I think the microphones are
probably worse as well no wireless
charging I think they are disappointing
you'd be much better off if you're an
Android User or even an iPhone user to
go for the nothing ear 2 and if you want
the overall best package with a lot of
extra features built into that case
great transparency mode uh go for the
airpods pro 2. of course they are
discounted now you can pick them up on
Amazon using links down below and you
guys let me know your thoughts if you
bought a pair of Beats but personally as
you guys could tell I'm a bit
disappointed go ahead and click that
Circle above to subscribe check out our
other comparisons right over there
that's been Max and I'll see you in the
next one
[Music]